[Music]
jake is in phoenix hey jake how are you
good how you guys doing this afternoon
better than we deserve what's up
yeah well uh well thanks for taking my
call i got two quick questions one for
ken one for you dave um
dave i'll start with you
quick background my wife and i are
debt-free um
and we're currently in baby step three
and expecting our first baby after a
difficult two years and um my question
is is i have a 2009 f-150 that has a
36-gallon fuel tank and we're going back
to a hybrid schedule for my current job
and one of our biggest expenses right
now is gas and i know everyone's
affected by this you're going back to a
hybrid schedule for your current oh
you're your current job you're losing
hours
i'm sorry i i didn't elaborate that very
well um i'm currently going
to back in the office two days a week
and i've been working from home in the
last
years or so hybrid meeting part at home
work i got you okay yes sir you got it
and um and so long story short with gas
prices in the large fuel tank um i think
last month alone we spent 1150 bucks
just on gas and so i'm contemplating
selling my truck it's paid off obviously
um
but just kind of trying to figure out if
that's a smart thing to do right now we
uh like i said we recently became debt
free which has been awesome what's your
what's your household income
household income net is 11 000 a month
um and then my wife is planning on going
part time
uh in december when we have our first
when we have our big boy
so
how much of the 11 000 is hers
out of the 11 000 let's see here there
is she's she's about to see about 6k of
it six thousand of it
you're gonna lose you're gonna lose 25
of your income all right and uh eleven
hundred dollars you're driving a long
way to work you're not even going to
work every day
you know i just we've we've had a my
wife and i have been going through
fertility treatment and um
our baby that we're having is an ivs
baby and dealt with recurrent
miscarriages so we've had a lot of
driving to certain doctors that aren't
really close
okay so it's not about it's not about
work then it was about all of that
yeah that that i think that's been a
part of it too and then now i'm trying
to take into account um
going back into the office now you know
and
how hard are you driving to work
it's about 40 miles around trip
okay so that's not an eleven hundred
dollar bill the 1100 bill had to do with
all the doctor runs
right which are not which are not
ongoing so you don't make a decision a
long-term decision based on a short-term
problem
now if you have a long-term problem
because you spend 1100 going to work
then that would be something else
because but you're not going to continue
these doctor runs at this rate
um when baby comes right
right right just just just now it'll be
office yeah which won't be anywhere near
eleven hundred dollars
uh unless you have the world's worst
f-150 but the um
uh so i mean what's your f-150 worth
it's probably worth around like 23 grand
okay so if you sold it what would what
price range uh car would you buy
part of me wants i'm torn probably wants
to buy a vehicle equal in value that
gets better gas mileage part of me wants
to
buy a ten thousand dollar vehicle
or you know maybe even fifteen thousand
dollar vehicle that gets better gas
mileage and then pocket the rest of the
funds as our emergency funds only got a
thousand dollars right now just from
paying off debt um and recently becoming
debt free and getting ready for the baby
yeah
i i if you're gonna be equal or move
down
and you're gonna save on a gas bill
um
then there's no reason not to do it
unless you just love the truck i
wouldn't i wouldn't worry about it you
know but if you're using some people use
this stuff as an excuse i want to move
to a
from a 23 000 car to a 50 000 tesla
because gas bill's killing me we are
never going to make up that in your
lifetime
so that's ridiculous math but you're
talking about moving equal or down i'm
fine with that